well Liz thank you for having us in Los
Angeles thank you are you from New York
City it just lifts your mood being here
right the sunshine hits different out
here it actually does you gotta have
that that vitamin D to really get you
going so thank you so much
um I'm really just happy to have you on
the show I feel like I have done such
just a deep dive into you with
everything that's you know out there on
the internet and I'm happy that you get
a chance to really tell people who you
are so I'm really looking forward to
this conversation I know that about a
year ago actually a year ago this month
is when you announced that you were
going to take a bit of a Hiatus and this
is the first kind of No Limits
conversation that you're having why is
this the time that you want to speak I'm
ready it's been a long year of
reflecting and growth and healing
um
I'm sick of being in an abusive
disrespectful situations change rooms
local rooms teams
um
been focusing on me you pray love and
I'm finally I'm finally in a place where
I'm ready to talk about it good yeah
okay so we will touch on all of that but
you mentioned healing and growth and I
know that in that initial Instagram post
you said that's what you wanted to focus
on when you wrote that post where were
you at mentally
probably rock bottom
I feel like to quit
in a middle of a season and walk away
from a team like it's got to be a bad
situation
um and I wasn't a very bad situation but
to to grow and heal you need to be away
from toxic situations you need healthy
environments to to grow and I've been
surrounded by nothing but loving life
since I I stepped away from the court
what about that situation made it so
toxic and which situation are you
referring to
well I think this box was really
just like a nail in the coffin
um
I joke with my friends that
a Hollywood lie you know bringing I I
came to La finally moved out to LA on a
Hollywood lie like a lot of lost souls
in Los Angeles I'm just another lost
soul in these streets no but I came here
with hopes and dreams of of
being the best and taking LA to
somewhere magical where it used to be
you know back in Lisa Leslie's day back
when Candace was here you know that's
what I grew up watching that's where I
always wanted to be at when I got
drafted I wanted to be playing here with
Candace that was always my dream but uh
you know I kept La as as the Pinnacle of
my dream even though a lot of people
warned me about playing for that club
and you know I got to I got to witness
it all firsthand
the lies I was told and I'm so happy I
have witnesses to everything I've been
through dinner's at catch you know with
GMS and ownership telling me they were
gonna get me a G-Wagon
and ownership told you they were gonna
get you a G wagon if you came and Sparks
we'll show you with any car you want I'm
talking g-wagons so maybe we'll get you
a GLE we're gonna help you extra you
know paying your rent in Bel Air
we're gonna pay with your your coaches
your medical staff
did any of that happen no
so you brought me here on lies
I'm dealing with you know a lot of
disrespect a lot of
turbulent players in the change room the
locker rooms and I'm telling the GM I'm
telling coaches I'm telling ownership
what's going on no one cares
no one cares so
I'm not the type of girl that's gonna
sit in a disrespectful
anything relationship workspace
anything I'ma leave there's one thing
I'm gonna do I'm gonna leave if I'm
uncomfortable and that's what I did
you're not paying me enough to put up
with this you haven't from the start
when I was 19 when I got drafted to the
WNBA
I played six seasons I'm 32 this year
I've just I've just never found a
situation that I feel comfortable in
that I feel secure in and that I feel
protected in and as a woman I need to
feel all these things to be the best I
can be
so let's zoom out from that a little bit
and unpack there's a lot of stuff there
but I want the viewers to really
understand the path that you have taken
in the WNBA so give an overview of your
past starting from that 2011 WNBA draft
little 19 year old Lizzy I had no idea
what I was getting myself into I was 18
and my careers advisor sat me down I was
at Australian Institute of sport it's
like a junior college we all go there
when we're 16.
I left just before attending 18 and they
sat me down they're like you can
go to college or you can go pro
they put this Australian contract on the
table I think it was like eighty
thousand dollars or something like
um I was like bet I'm not even 18 yet
I'm like bet let me take that money so
I'm already making money at 17.
they're like okay now the WBA is
interested in you you'll go into the the
draft I was like cool
Minnesota had number one pick Myanmar
mind you I don't even know who Maya
Moore was I didn't know I don't know I
didn't grow up watching college I've
just gotten into March Madness I love
I'm so obsessed with college now yeah
I'm like is there any way I can go back
and play in college have any eligibility
I do I know I've been a pro for 15 years
but is there any way I can run it back
and get a little college education and
who beat these girls because they're so
fun absolutely and they're so lovely and
I love those girls so much and I protect
them at any cost but I didn't know
anything I didn't know ball I just
hooped when I was a kid I was just tall
as [__] got thrown into the ranks you
know it was really good picked the game
up really good
no one could stop me still no one can
stop me no one can stop me and you can
go ahead you're gonna have to send a
triple team double team one-on-one no
other female can stop me and that's on
period
say it I believe it I'm saying it girl I
believe it every day I know it and
you're saying you knew that even 17 18
before you were I didn't know it then
okay I really didn't believe it until I
broke the record okay I really didn't
like step into my own truth and own who
I am until I broke the record
but yeah it's been a journey like
there's been so much and that's why
taking some time away and really
reflecting I started writing my book
like no matter what I've been through my
mother was always like to save it for
the book a lot of things that happened
to me I haven't been vocal about because
save it for the book yeah it gets ready
to get stuff save it for the best seller
girl so for the draft Minnesota had the
pick yes sorry I am more it's okay we're
back Maya Moore Maya Moore of course is
number one honestly one of the greatest
that I've watched play male female one
of the greatest admire in China a whole
different a whole different Maya a bit
I'm I
she told me who she was like real quick
yeah real quick and she's really one of
the ghosts of the game but yeah my
number one I ended up going to Tulsa
Oklahoma I said publicly don't take me
don't take me to Tulsa Oklahoma no shade
to Tulsa Oklahoma but I was 19 years old
from Melbourne Australia like little
little brat from like one of the coolest
cities in the world and you send me to
Tulsa Oklahoma when all I want to do is
play in LA and be in La go but I'm also
so thankful that I wasn't 19 years old
in La yeah and I didn't get here there's
a lot to get into I didn't get here till
I was 30. I wasn't living out here until
I was like 28 30. so that was God
protecting me in a way
but yeah Tulsa Oklahoma cried every day
we won three games for the season
it was one of the most Rock Bottom times
of My Life
um didn't have much support like a 19
year ago on a team I didn't have any
vets looking out out for me after me
because I don't know in professional
sport you do have to look after yourself
I get that but when you put a 19 year
old into a situation like that
you need you need some support around
that you want the foundation yeah yeah
and I don't feel like I was asking too
much
like I said I wanted to be in LA because
it's easier for my family it's a 15-hour
flight Melbourne La I don't want them to
have to go another four hours to get to
Oklahoma and then we get to Tulsa
so I'm always
everything I've wanted to do my family's
been at the Forefront of my mind I never
played in Europe because it's so far
away from my family in Australia so I
always played in China made all my money
hooping in China
Miss China that's why I'm not hooping
right now is because China isn't open a
lot of people like why aren't you in the
WNBA la la la la because it doesn't pay
me
but if China opens up again please
please open up again I will be there
that's where I want to be so when you
went to Tulsa and then you left for five
years or so and that's when you were
playing overseas but also back and forth
well so WPA is on during the summer time
and if you're not in the WNBA usually
doing national team training or you're
just enjoying summer like I do I just
enjoying my summertime but in the time
where you were in between Tulsa and then
the year before when they were in Dallas
what were you doing in that time
enjoying my Summers even if I if it
wasn't summer time I'd be in China in
the winter okay and I think there was a
couple of Australian seasons in there as
well okay so you come back to the States
they're Dallas Wings well actually I had
a year off as well okay 2017 I I did a
big like Euro trip did Burning Man
um all the fun things it was just like
being 25 years old and it was it was
interesting before I took that year off
uh
an old Australian coach pulled me to the
side
and he was like you'll never come back
for this you can't take a year off
you'll never come back from this
baby I came back I broke records after a
year and a half off I feel like a lot of
people don't realize that just putting
something down you could be writing your
book you could be painting a picture you
could be trying to make a song
if you get to a mental block and you
just walk away refresh your refresh your
mind take a breather and come back to it
you'll come back better you'll come back
with a bigger hunger more inspiration
and that's what happened to me every
time I take a break away from the game
I'm still working on my craft I'm still
with Chris and the guys in the valley
two or three times a week getting my ass
kicked by seven foot men like but I love
that I don't get that playing with the
girls I don't get pushed around I don't
get to throw my weight like that like I
do with grown men and I think that's
truly why I'm so happy just training
with guys in the summertime and not even
in the league because I don't have to
shrink myself
for them you know I get to be everything
I am on court when I'm playing with guys
I even trained with the seven now I
don't even play with the six I train
with a men's ball shoot better with a
men's ball as well yeah
um
I don't even know what I was talking
about that's what I mean I go off girl
well not to not to interrupt you but it
seems I can correct me if I'm wrong
there has been this kind of
threat in your life where maybe somebody
has said you are one thing or aren't one
thing you've maybe internalized it in
some way and you look to either prove
them wrong prove yourself right whatever
the case may be but you have just you've
named a few instances where a person
kind of served as motivation for you
would you say that that's accurate I
don't even think that was motivation
like him saying that I was just like
you're an old man like what like
like you're literally so old like what
are you even saying to me
like I'm a bounce back and better than
ever it wasn't even something that was
like even on my mind like that until I
did break the record I was just like
that's just God shutting everyone else
up for me like my whole life has just
been people talking about me when I when
every time I haven't wanted to play in
the WNBA as many rumors about where I am
what I'm doing this and that because I
don't let people know where I'm at I
don't want people to know what I'm doing
like my life is so private no you
couldn't name one person I've ever dated
and that's for a reason I don't want
people to know my true life and I really
like people like she's disappeared she's
gone I'm living I just don't show people
what I'm doing because I feel like when
you show people how great everything
truly is they want to take it away they
want to put [__] on it they evil lie
I've had a lot of evil eyes taken off me
and I'm just in a place where I'm like
you know what it's better for me to just
not even tell y'all what I'm up to where
I'm at what I'm doing and you just don't
know so with that being said with you
saying you're private and you're very
intentionally trying to not show people
what you're doing what do you feel is
the perception of you
I don't really know I think people think
I'm this Troublemaker people I've got
ESPN reporters saying on air that I'm
toxic I wish someone would tell me why
you know I left that Vegas team
after the first game of that season
asked for a trade mind you
um had teammates families and friend
friends bullying me bullying my friends
on Twitter we have it all saved we have
it all screenshot you try to delete it
all we still got it it's okay you're
saying you were being bullied by Aces
teammates
mm-hmm but I leave that organization and
I keep my mouth closed like I said I
don't need to talk badly about things I
just move on it's like a bad breakup I'm
not going to talk about my ex I'm gonna
look forward people who talk about their
exes after a breakup of weird it's weird
Behavior like move on
but I'm I leave this team I look on to
better days but you've still got girls
talking about me in training camp with
girls aren't even on the team like why I
call Rookies coming up to me telling me
what so-and-so is saying like why why my
old Aces teammates texting La teammates
about me but you girls never said
anything to me while I was there but you
want to call me toxic
these are the girls I was reporting for
kicking my [__] in locker rooms and I'm
toxic these are the girls that are
trying to sell fake stories about me to
ESPN my own teammates that I'm playing
basketball with
and they're calling me toxic
um give me an example can you give me an
example I'm not gonna say no names you
don't have to say names but it's like
you don't have to say names which is
what you mean by that I always get like
my packages sent to like the offices
open up my offices and open up the boxes
in the change room
why have I got I'm opening my boxes
teammates coming in kicking my stuff
everywhere
I just like I'm not going to react to
that because I'm not a child and I'm not
going to get into because it's like
your mentality is weird why am I gonna
go back and forth with you I'm just here
to hoop
I know I've never sworn at anyone in
locker rooms I've never said anything
horrible to anyone in locker rooms I
just I just think it's really
interesting that when I leave a
situation I fire agent I move on to
better days
all these people have negative things to
say
it's very much to me it's like you can't
control me you can't control my image so
you try to
put [__] on a you try to talk down on me
well I I move on and I grow
and people just stick around talking
about me I don't really understand the
so you think the perception from people
in your eyes incorrectly that you are a
troublemaker this is a broad question
but why do you feel as though that does
keep happening to you because I speak my
mind
I'm not scared of anything
I'm not scared of a high institution I'm
not scared of losing my job I'm not
scared of losing my spot on a team I'm
not scared of what so-and-so thinks of
me I think I'm the only girl that's like
at 19 that was like no to a team taking
me being a woman that knows what she
wants is afraid to say that or go after
it people don't like that people don't
like my confidence
I'm just me like I don't I just the way
I've been raised blame it on my mama
talk to her
at the end of the day people want to
talk about things that I haven't even
done
it's like the things you've shade the
negative light with on me I haven't even
done those things
so if somebody said to you what is the
reason you're not in the WNBA what would
your answer be you don't pay me enough
you do not pay me enough to warm up this
Achilles every other day and hoop and
get the [__] beaten out of me on court
to then sit in a commercial seat
tomorrow
I'm six nine bro I do not belong in an
exit row I fly myself business anywhere
I go is business premium economy I have
not seen the back of a plane
unless I'm in the WBA it's the only time
I see it and I'm not upgrading my own
seat to get to work y'all should be
paying that
I'm six nine two forty five and you got
me uncomfortable then to play a game run
around every other day it's just the the
cons really outweigh the pros for me to
being in the WNBA and it's been that way
since I was 19 years old
I did the maths the other day and for
the six seasons I played in the WNBA I
think it came to 900k before
tax
that was my last Chinese contract for
one season
and that's you got for six in the w
what does that make you feel about
your value here very low
I don't think there's a more depressing
time than
um when like June July comes around and
those NBA guys are signing their
contracts like I love that for them it's
amazing for them
but as a woman knowing that my Max here
is 200k and that's the ceiling that is
the gloss roof that's the ceiling you
can't go through that
I can't even do extra work as well
like when I was working when I was
playing for Vegas I couldn't DJ in Vegas
because MGM owned all of the strip on
the team
and that that's the
it's against the CBA and so that's my
issue people like oh you hate Becky
Hammond for making a million dollars
that is not what I said that is not what
I said I think every woman in the whole
world deserves a million dollars you
deserve a million dollars you deserve a
million we all grow we go through it we
all deserve our coin but when you have a
coach
that is making
I think a whole team's salary sorry
um salary cap is 1.3 for a whole team
you know a max player is on 200 you know
the coach is making five times the max
player like
I'm sorry that math is so disrespectful
to me and it's not taking away from a
coach making a million dollars it's it's
the CBA and the limitations of the
players making more money that's my
issue is the CBA and it has been from
day one I don't understand the media
constantly trying to twist the things I
say into a negative way when all I want
is better for women
I really don't understand it so you're
saying your issue is more so about the
dispersal of this money why is only one
type of person getting this million
dollars how can we make the playing
field level for everybody involved and
you feel like that message has been lost
in translation for you it's been so lost
when it was just literally one tweet I
don't understand how one tweet that
literally said the dumb NBA where a
coach can make a million dollars and
play is it was like 200. I think that
was the tweet
but people take that and just like
manipulate it I just I just don't
understand it I don't understand I miss
the days when like journalists really
went off to the truth well they actually
wrote a story and like interviewed
people when I went and hooped in Israel
this year it was really funny I um I saw
a daily mail I saw a Daily Mail article
about me growing a hoop in Israel saying
oh it's the end of Liz's career this is
the this is her falling out la la la I
was like the biggest sign that Israel
has ever seen and I did that just from a
coach calling me and filling in for
Kalani Brown if it was Kalani if it
wasn't Kalani Brown injured I would not
have gone but I wanted to like help that
girl out and keep the team happy
and it was like the best time of my life
I made friends forever I had the best
time in ashdod shout out my coffee Astro
because that was one of the best
situations I've ever hooped in but this
this this journalist wanted to make it
the most
you know disrespectful end of her days
blah blah blah type article
I look her up this is me this is what I
do you want to write something bad about
me you you comment crazy things about me
I'll go on your profile I'll look you up
check out your LinkedIn find your
Facebook
this is my thing you know I just got a
little kick out of it and I see how
you're living
and I see how sad that is and I see I
see a lot of sports journalists like you
wanted to be what I am you want to be
doing what I am this that was your dream
you wanted to be a pro cricketer
but you're not and you hate to see women
like me doing the thing doing whatever
they want how they like
and you're in an office writing about me
and making it as negative as you can
because that's what's in your heart
do you think
that there is a part of you that may be
without even realizing it so do you
watch Game of Thrones I I do
and that's a bit of a tangent but there
is this scene in Game of Thrones where
Ty when Lannister is talking to Jamie
yes and Tywin is like you care too much
what people think about you and then
Jamie says I couldn't care less what
people think about me and then Tywin
goes
I think that's what you want people to
think about you
um
do you think you really are okay
with what people think of you in a
vacuum I'm only asking you because it
feels like what you're explaining is
somebody who is internalizing what
people are saying in some way which I
think is natural I think every human
being says they don't care what people
say about them I do the same thing but
I'm also aware of what they said and
more importantly I'm aware of how it
made me feel
did it make you feel the way that this
journalist said this about you even
though you know it's not true but I've
seen articles about you I did extensive
research on you and I'm sure it has to
be a lot that there are so many people
saying things about you and you think so
much of it isn't true there's no way you
can just always brush that off it's fast
it is frustrating like I've I've had
blogs about me on the internet since I
was 15 years old if I truly cared what
people said about me I'd be dead by now
like I've lost friends of suicide due to
Australian media I've seen friends
hospitalized from the attacks lashed out
from media in Australia it's different
UK Australian media is very different
and there's different protective laws as
well like you can't just like sue
someone for defamation in Australia
there's a lot of past uh plays in
Australia members of the board
um who have used their platforms to lie
about me lie about relationships with me
um I just just speak on me negatively to
take away from the true issues with
basketball Australia I feel like I'm
used as a scapegoat for a lot of things
just my name gets thrown into things
just as a scapegoat um
but I can't if I if I truly can I don't
think I would be here if I was like oh
she said this and this and this people
have talked about me my whole life and
the bigger you are the more people are
going to talk about you absolutely so
then let's let's clear some things up I
want to get your perspective on a few
things so the last time we saw you
playing in the WNBA was July of last
year with the Sparks can you walk me
through that day of your last game I
believe it was July 23rd of last year we
were in Vegas we were in Vegas
and I remember
it was funny I remember seeing
um
Mark before the game and growing up and
hugging Mark and
he's been he's been a really big um
what's so what in inspiration for
women's sports just for how much he's
like trying to put Mark Davis yeah Mark
Davis sorry Mark Davis uh just give
women everything they deserve over in
Vegas you know being
getting to see him work and how he goes
about things is is really special
because I feel like a lot of owners just
use the WB as a tax write-off you don't
really care like it's just a flex like
owning it but you're like Mark cares
because like you just pretend to like be
cool and care about women's sports like
own a WNBA team
y'all not cold outside
how are you the owner of a team I've
seen you at one game
but anyway I saw Mark that day gave me a
big hug I was like you make you he makes
me want to be an owner one day he makes
me want to get my money to a place where
I can own teams and really like put
women on a pedestal
um the somak went in the locker room
was warming up for the game and then I
remember being on court that game I had
some friends in Vegas that night as well
remember being on call and just like
a few disrespectful teammates yelling at
me because they don't know how to throw
a love pass to me in the pose
I'm just like you're saying Sparks
demons yeah I'm just like I'm really
dealing with like girls just yelling at
me because they're frustrated without
how they don't know how to throw the
ball to me
our coaching staff doesn't want to teach
them like how to use a post player like
me
I remember running down the court and a
girl that was like a really frustrated
me in Vegas while I was there like
stepped in front of me and took a charge
as I'm like running down
the car I was like okay this is just
another straw in the camel's back
and then it was like another play and
this teammate of mine came up and was
just like yelling at me again I get
subbed off
I sit on the bench I sit down next to
Shanae I'm like I'm done like this is it
I'm done mind you like we've had like a
lot of issues throughout this season
like we coach got fired Jim got fired
a load of plays in and out a lot of
players injured and sick
I'm just like I'm done I have nothing to
give anymore there's just too much going
on in this situation like I'm 30 years
old and you're yelling at me because you
can't pass me the ball
for not enough money like if you were
paying me more I might be able to deal
with this and like suck it up and move
on but as a 30 year old woman who has
been in these situations professionally
for 15 years I'm just done I'm just done
like I came to this team
I I took a pay cut to you know help the
team be better
I'm just like y'all not doing anything
to control these situations these locker
rooms is even coach this team I'm good
because right now not only do I feel
stupid I look stupid as well and there
ain't nothing worse than looking dumb
you had said I believe in your own words
in that post that it was abrupt
why do you feel like you left so
abruptly
in that moment I was just when I'm done
I'm done like when I'm done like I
really just had an epiphany in the
middle of the game I was like I'm done
so you didn't know until the game that I
was like halfway I was literally halfway
through the game sat on the bench looked
at Shanae was like I'm done
I packed my stuff up after the game I
said I wish y'all the best of luck met
my friends we went to Denim a Tau went
home drove with one of the rookies home
the next day back to LA from Vegas
that was it the owner didn't want to
talk to me GM didn't want to talk to me
talk to the coach she was cool with it
I was getting text messages from stuff
like if we don't win today I'm gonna
quit
tonight this is from staff members
we would have game day I'd have people
ready to sit Courtside and they'll be
like you can't have your friends
Courtside today we are so far in the red
we need people to buy tickets
you're telling me this on game day as
I'm driving to the game and I've got
like celebrities sitting cold side like
it's just there's a level of
professionalism
that I like to work at and if
you're not meeting it I'm probably going
to walk away from the situation call me
a diva call me whatever you want but at
the end of the day I'm just a woman who
knows what she wants and knows how she
likes to operate on a professional level
this is meant to be the Pinnacle of
professional sports
do you have any regrets at all about the
way you did it and just just to play
Devil's Advocate the reason I say that
is because
there will be people that are going to
see what you just said and say did you
feel like there's professionalism in the
way that you left
I got lied too about g-wagons
like I've been lied to I got lied to on
so many levels I got played with you
think I'm gonna sit around and be played
with and care about if it's professional
or not
you think I care that deeply when I sit
here and I tell you everything that I
went through I feel like people are
going to understand oh that's why she
dipped and I didn't really want to just
sit there and talk badly all of a sudden
like I had to go heal from some from
some other stuff and just get away from
a toxic world like when I'm gone I'm
gone like this possible stuff really
hasn't even been in the Forefront of my
mind like it's been a reason of like
yeah I've just can't take this [__]
anymore but
there's been a lot of other things I've
had to focus on here so you've mentioned
a few times you know that there was a
bunch of reasons why you felt like that
moment wasn't working for you why is
that what are some of the things that
you're just gonna do anymore
um Drive downtown every day
I was living in Bel Air that drive to
downtown when you don't even want to go
to work is Pretty Tough like when you
wake up and you're like I don't want to
do this it's not a knife it's not a nice
way to live when you're living
and you're really unhappy with what
you're doing like that really affects my
mental health and me protecting my
mental health will always be number one
because I've been I've been dragged for
these situations and made to feel like
[__] from a young age
I was trying to think what else was
happening when I was there because
there's this is a lot there's really a
lot but the lying just like don't lie to
me don't lie to me have you gotten a
chance to tell those people that you
feel lied to you how you feel about no
those people haven't spoken to me
that they wouldn't even speak to me when
I wanted to quit what would you say if
you could talk to them I don't really
have anything to say
I don't like
I don't I don't expect an apology I
don't expect apologies from anyone
that's spoken badly about me or done
wrong to me I don't I just move I just
move away from it I don't need you like
if you treat me badly you show me those
true colors like I don't really want an
apology or to be your friend or to carry
on working with you
it's just like you've shown me who you
are I know this already
how much of a role in that game your
last game with the Sparks how much of a
role did it play that it was against
your former team
um I think just being in Vegas I was
very triggered just like that that a lot
of stuff happens in that City even the
year before it was the year before since
the the Australian national team stuff
where I got assaulted
it's like no one talks about that people
want to talk about things that didn't
even happen within that within that
scrimmage but no one wants to talk about
the reasons of why I didn't play or
wouldn't sorry why I didn't want to play
that game and why I ended up assaulted
and I'm playing the All-Star Game the
next day because I had concussion
oh don't worry I'll let you talk about
it I'll tell you when it gets there I
got you I got one wants to talk about
that no one wants to talk about the
truth and a lot of the truth I haven't
been ready to speak on like I've really
been abused and assaulted in this world
of Boss ball and not protected and I've
had to get to a place where I'm ready to
speak on it
there's a word that I have heard you say
a lot as I'm reading things about you
that there have been moments that you
have felt unsafe or unsupported when is
a time that you did feel safe and
supported in the w
hmm
[Music]
it's hard because I'm I'm one of those
girls that come in with a big Target now
we're coming with the personality I come
in with the following I come in with the
game and girls don't like that
um you know defending me is be physical
with me and found me and hit me it's not
play her straight up so put a body on
her it's like beat the [__] out of her
own court and then referees want to even
up the game and just let it happen
and I'm fine with that happening in
China like you know you know it's going
to be tough in China like there's people
paying off referees like is there's a
lot of money going on in China
but to just be constantly like treated
like that on court when you're
benefiting off my image of me being here
as well
it's just like not it's not protective
it's not a situation I'm not Shaq
[Laughter]
I'm not like I'm a girl I'm just a girl
that likes to hoop and it's just you
guys try to continuously turn me into
like you want me to be this Beast you
want me to be this you want me to be
that I'm just Liz yo I'm just a big
growly that hooped for a little bit and
has a lot of other interests
and I feel like because basketball isn't
my Do or Die situation like I'm not out
there shooting on the court to my hands
bleed I don't need to I'm cash my shots
cash I've been getting my work but I
don't really need to be out there
shooting until my hands bleed
and it's just gets a little bit Black
Swan you know the one to be the best
some people want it so bad that they
want to take other people out of the
light so they can take it for themselves
well what sticks out to me about what
you just said is that you didn't have an
answer to a time that you felt safe or
supported are you saying that you've
never in your career felt that way
probably not I think the happiest I ever
was was the dollar that Dallas season I
was surrounded by really great girls had
a really great coach
but even in that situation did not trust
the GM owner still down Shady things
happen the way Fred was fired that
season I was brought back to that team
with the promise that if I didn't enjoy
the season I would be traded they wanted
to keep me I had to go have a mental
breakdown on Instagram about them you
know not treating me like a human lying
to me once again I think that's why
people really hate me it's like I'm not
scared to like go crazy on social media
like I'm not scared I'm not scared to
cry I'm not scared to show my emotions
I'm not scared to show you how I feel
because that's who I am that's what I'm
feeling
it's like why why do you get to lie to
me in close doors and private rooms but
I can't show my emotions or tell the
truth to the world
I'll never understand it
so was the switch as you talk about the
Sparks because you know there was a time
where you were saying that that was when
you felt the most safe and supported
when you first got there and you were
talking about how much you were enjoying
your time
when did that switch happen oh girl I
was lying
I was really lying like it was from
training camp that this box situation
was bad and that's the thing like I
really tried to keep the peace and
believe in it for a long time but
Mike we had our training camp uh in the
Lakers facility right
we're still doing weights in Alleyways
and Ice baths in the car park
but we're using we're in the Lakers
facility we can't use their Recovery
Center we can't use their weight room
we're really doing ice bars in the car
park of the Lakers facility that's that
was probably some of the most
disrespectful
times I've really felt I was like damn
this really reminded me of us uh when
Sedona posted all that stuff yeah to
join the tournament I'm like damn like
this is really meant to be the Pinnacle
I was like yeah I'm a spocks like we're
doing a training camp with the with the
Lakers facility I was so excited people
like wait till you see the game room
wait to see the big gold door in the
game room
see that I didn't even see a weights
room people coming up to me talking
about how amazing the Lakers facilities
I wouldn't know I would not know
I saw one practice call an Alleyway
where we did Wades and then the cold
tubs in the car park
and this is meant to be the start of our
season
and then we move to another training
training facility which was like the
worst thing I've ever seen we walked
into that place I went straight up to
the GM I said what is this this is the
worst I said this is the worst facility
I've ever seen in the dumb NBA you said
that yes in his response
tell our owner
even though he lied straight he was the
one who organized the whole thing but
wants to lie to me and pretend it was
the owners doing
please don't lie to me don't play games
with me
I'm not the one to be played with well
there's been a lot of mention just kind
of of moments that you've had with other
people you know anytime that there are
big events or big shifts many
relationships do get strained but is
there a relationship in the WNBA that
you wish you commend
because meant
no no one
no
no really
no and the people that are your former
teammates where do your relationships
stand with them I only ask because you
know they're going to see you talking
about the game or them not being able to
throw them past you or the other things
that you said they're gonna have
thoughts about that thing what do you
feel about that
I feel like people will always have like
memories of me and for me it's just like
something that happened in passing
I feel like that's a big thing like
I don't know my friends have my number I
still have best friends in the league I
still watch them hoop on the little app
it's impossible to find those games on
TV but I'm still watching on the app
um and supporting how I can and I still
get all the ghosts all the tea I still
get the phone calls I don't really care
for it but people want to keep me in the
loop
I don't know but I would I would love to
play in The W I would love for it to be
a situation where I'm I'm happy to
see money in my bank account and I'm
getting to work safely and feeling good
but being stuck in a little exit row
when you want me to play 40 minutes
tomorrow is just not feasible for me and
my body Mind and Spirit
um being in locker rooms where like a
lot of these women need
like mental help because we do a lot
we're on the road a lot we travel a lot
if we're not in America the girls are
probably overseas in Europe there's a
lot going on and I've seen a lot of
alcohol abuse over the years I've seen a
lot of gambling issues over the years
I've seen a lot of issues I'm I speak on
my stuff openly
but there's girls that need a lot of
help in these locker rooms
so the onus to change the league
obviously isn't on you or any of the
players it is on the powers that be to
figure out how to make it work for all
people it's not your responsibility no
but what is it that you want to see in
these things that you're looking to
change is there anything that you are
wanting to do to help that change move
forward I've offered my help no one
wants it you know I I saw gaps in
marketing
um as a like as the girly athlete
um and I lent into it I really went into
it because no one else was doing it I
found a way to mock it myself to the
point where I make more money off Court
than I ever did Encore in the WBA
um
and I know a lot of people don't have
that mentality like I'm in businesses in
Australia own a vitamin company I own
gyms starting two fashion labels here
but I drop myself thank you girl I gotta
get you some gotta get you some but like
I've always had a business by my mom's a
CEO and that's where a lot of my fashion
comes from as well is watching her go to
work in suits that's why I always wear
suits to games because I'm going to work
it's business
um but you know marketing I love I love
business I love numbers I love analytics
and I love making money
um you know I've helped a lot of the
girls with their marketing stuff as well
and and given them you know help with
what they need if it's styling if it's
trying to find a new agent manage uh if
they should stay in college or if they
should go to the WNBA like I'm always
there to help but I just don't think
people really want to listen to me
because I've just like said too much
already
like why would why would you want to go
get help from the girl that's already
said so much [__] about y'all
it's not like but I mean that's I don't
know what do you feel is the answer to
that that's a fair I don't feel like I'm
talking [__] I've just been open and
honest and I feel like people take that
negatively like I don't want to talk
[__] about it it's just like you don't
pay me enough like forty thousand
dollars as a rookie for a whole summer
is not enough it wasn't enough money for
me as a 19 year old so I left the WNBA
for four years came back played a couple
of Seasons gone again like that's how I
operate I'm two and I'm from and I I
don't think people don't like that I'm a
little bit of a free spirit if this
isn't serving me I'll go to like this
I'll go focus on this if that's done
I'll go focus on something else I'm so
add I have so many interests I have so
many passions that if one thing isn't
feeding me I'm just focusing on the
other thing yeah but I mean going off of
that the ordeal with the Sparks that was
the third time that you're able to force
your way out of a team and I'm sure some
people see that and they think that is a
Liz pattern do you know how many people
like the team like I know girls that
have played on every team
like getting moving around in the WBA in
the NBA it isn't it isn't rare
like look at Katie how many teams Katie
been on look at look at any player any
player how many teams I've been on
Candace this has been on three and she
spent like her whole life in La I've
seen girls that have been on five
different teams people get tossed around
in the dumb NBA I feel like I'm the only
person that's like no I don't want to go
there no I don't want to go there yes I
do want to go here I want to get out of
here
like I'd forced my way out of these
situations like I forced my way out of
these situations I haven't been pushed
out of any situations I've left
everything I've been a part of I've left
Tulsa Dallas I left Vegas I left text
messages trying to resign me I left
La I left in the middle of the season
it's just the it's the media's
just constant takedown of me that's so
crazy that it's like I've been on three
teams and that looks negative when it's
just literally the normal thing yeah in
this career
um do you think though when you think
about all of this you think about what
the media is saying because I do agree
generally the media when I see the media
I mean I'm a part of the media the media
you're different I'm sorry but you're so
different like I feel like you really
take the time to like interact and get
to know the athletes and when other
journalists try to do it because like
you see I'm getting it I'm getting it
I'm going
but like which I appreciate it you don't
have to I truly you're real at the at
the at the beginning of the day like
you're you're real and you're doing this
from your heart you don't have to do the
cloud stuff people are just naturally
attracted to you and trust you a lot of
these guys trust you and want to be
around you we don't want to be around
other journalists
guys kicking ESPN reporters out of their
section they're trying to be cool with
it and you know you're not getting
kicked out of sections people want to be
around you thank you there's other
journalists out here that are so hungry
and thirsty for any story that they
write anything but you got integrity and
you're real I agree so you're different
that is very kind that is very kind
truly that is a great compliment so that
makes you smile thank you I do think the
me the job that I am a part of I am a
part of the media
what a lot of times that we are doing is
seeing the information that's presented
to us and sometimes when there are gaps
or things that we don't know when the
person isn't talking your job is to give
your opinion and sometimes with that
people end up forming conclusions that
maybe sound like their fact even though
their opinion and I think that what is
happening with you or at least it seems
like there are a lot of things that are
inside of you that you're like I either
haven't talked about this or I didn't
get the space and there's things that I
want to say but there's just so many
question marks surrounding it that it
has allowed people to fill in the gaps
of the things that they don't know does
that make sense and I'm you're not doing
anything wrong with that you have the
absolute right to speak when you want to
speak and not speak when you don't want
to speak
but I think people are maybe more so
curious with the things that have
happened to you A lot of them that you
have described have not been fair but
what role do you feel like you have
played in how things have gone in your
career
[Music]
I don't know I'm just a girl that's been
trying to who it's like when I have to
deal with blackface a teammate doing
blackface stuff on the Australian team
like I was painted as the racist
troublemaker
for being upset about a teammate doing
blackface
and that's on that was put on me that
was put on me okay
I've just been in so many situations
like like you said I don't want to talk
I don't want to talk about it I don't
need to talk I don't feel like I don't
need to talk about it because and then
because I don't say anything reporters
will fill it in and just say literally
anything
so the the gaps in your career yeah if
you were just attributing it to one
thing one thing yeah what is that thing
for you
like when I've not been playing like
whatever yeah or not been playing or not
been happy or figuring things out what
do you feel like just is that reason
that for you it isn't working because it
seems like you feel like this is
experience is specific to Liz if that
makes sense I think I'm just different I
think I made a lot of money very young
overseas uh in China and I learned
quickly like my wife and my value and I
don't I don't sit in situations where
I'm not valued and as an athlete you can
just get treated like a piece of me and
I know I'm a human and I don't let
people treat me like a piece of meat I
don't like people use me I don't let
people play me
and I'll just walk away from a situation
I don't think people can just walk away
um and I think that that comes from me
having other interests and other
businesses like I'm not just a hoopa I'm
very very good at basketball but I also
have a business portfolio that no one
else in the WBA has
like
I remember when I was going to Vegas the
first the first season Bill wanted me in
Vegas I was like I need 10 days to pack
up my house
um and just get things right with my
business before I leave he's like no you
need to leave tomorrow I said okay that
doesn't work for me
um stay here let me know if you still
want me in 10 days two weeks
two weeks later he calls me get on the
flat and come here okay
I'm the type of girl that's gonna pull
my foot down and do things my way you
can call that toxic I have other things
and other interests that need to be
taken care of I'm still going to get to
training camp give you 30 20 every other
game
I'm still going to do my job
I might not be buddy buddy with all the
girls because it gets very [__] and
gossipy and I'm just like since high
school I've tried to stay away from that
I don't I don't like gossip I don't like
that environment that's probably another
thing like a lot of people just gossip
about me you don't know anything about
me you don't know what my home life
looks like you don't even know what my
house looks like you don't even know
where I live you literally don't even
have my phone number like all these
people talk about me like you know me
you don't even have my phone number like
it's so fun it's frustrating no I I feel
that that's like that's like the most
frustrating thing is it's like people
talking on you and you don't even know
me I don't even talk to you I would
never even give you the time of day like
that's honestly the most frustrating
thing as I hate using celebrity words as
someone who's known someone who has a
following that is the most frustrating
thing is just like people talking like
they know something
well I do want to talk about something
you have touched on a bit
um and that is in line with this and
that is the altercation with the
Nigerian team obviously there were
reports of a physical and verbal
altercation between your Australian team
and the Nigerian team and a report says
that you called The Players monkeys and
told them to go back to their third
world country you have vehemently denied
these reports yes but there is also a
group of people that say that you did
say these things
why are these stories so drastically
different
oh
a lot of girls don't like me and a lot
of times
I say no to something people really
want to make me look like the issue I
never wanted to go into that Olympics I
spent the whole week
going into that bubble saying I don't
want to be in the bubble show you text
messages between me and Sandy brondello
I do not want to go to this Olympics I
do not want to be a part of this
Olympics I do not believe in this
Olympics I feel like
the Tokyo Olympics is everything against
what the true Olympics is like Olympics
is about Nations coming together not
weird bubbles I was I'm very not a
bubble girl I have anxiety I need to be
able to leave situations like that like
I'm very much I walk into a room I know
where the exit is and going into the
WNBA bubble I didn't want to do that I
just that was going to be my worst
nightmare going to a an Olympic bubble I
didn't want to do that so much pressure
like this is the Pinnacle of
Sports is the Olympics I'm already
struggling mentally and physically
I was I'm open and honest about
everything we had
we were in a bubble right it's funny the
media reported that I I was breaking the
bubble going clubbing in Vegas I never
broke a bubble people broke the bubble
to meet with me though to try and get me
on the team
I went and did the team I realized my my
number one person I needed there my my
uh my psychologist wasn't has been
kicked off the team and we're not taking
a psychologist to the Olympics I do not
want to be a part of this I if there's
one place I need mental help it's at the
Olympics that is the most pressure
cooker of a situation and it's like I'm
not just going to the Olympics like to
sit on the bench it's like you want me
carrying this team that's what I do get
on my back let's go I'm gonna take you
to a medal
it's like I'm already coming to the
coach and the captain Rock Bottom
dealing with like relationship drama
dealing with like Vegas drama dealing
with like All-Star team drama you
couldn't name a woman that was on three
different teams a week leaving into the
Olympics I was on the All-Star team I
was on the Olympic team I was on the
Vegas team I had to tell Vegas I was
missing games to go join this bubble
I go into the bubble our head coaches
and even there
our head coach is still coaching the
WNBA and you've got me in this bubble
okay I'm talking with the doctors my
achilles is messed up they put me on
steroids straight away I'm already Blake
getting using Valium to get through the
day
I'm stressed so stressed about life I
just knew that a situation like the
Olympics was not it for me that year
so I've already gone into this situation
vulnerable being open and honest about
everything going on my life like girls
on that team knew
outside of basketball what I was going
through and that I think it's really
sick and twisted that because I didn't
want to be a part of the Olympics and
I'm just it's another thing I can walk
away from but y'all need me there
and because I didn't want to be there
you want to ruin my image and my
reputation because I don't want to be on
your team it's like I said it's like
dealing with weird exes why are you
talking about me just for clarification
because I had said why are the stories
so drastically different and you had
said because you said you say it's
because you feel like the girls don't
like you what do you mean by girls the
both teams wanting what do you work for
this one girl that's been saying that I
called them
monkeys and words like that's not I'll
call you a [__] I'll call you a dumb
[__] that's that's what I say to people
when we get into it I don't really lean
towards racially
you know backed
like insults that's not how I go I'm
very pro-black so you maintain that you
did not say yeah this girl that's saying
all these things right had a lot to say
about me lick the tapes I've never owned
the tapes leak the tapes you all want to
see the truth lead to tapes everyone in
Australia has seen the tape still lying
about what's on these tapes leak the
tapes
so I guess I guess that still does you
know beg the question because at the end
of the day it is one person saying that
you said one thing one person saying
they didn't
and the truth is somewhere in there and
no only people that know other people
that were there yeah but
I guess it's just why why would
something
as bad as this happen because the truth
looks a lot worse for other
organizations involved than using me as
a scapegoat like why does Nigeria want
me to leave Australia and go represent
them
why are we about you're saying right now
we're filing for me to leave the
Australian team so I can represent
Nigeria because Nigeria would like you
to join the team I've been in cahoots
I've been talking with them since all of
this happened
this is what I mean people don't know
people don't know the truth no I don't
haven't I honestly haven't had one like
journalist that's written all these lies
like actually come to me and want my
side of the story like there's a whole
tape with the truth out there I want it
out there like put it out there put it
out there let the people see I don't own
it I've never owned it I didn't even
have it when everything happened I
couldn't even protect myself with a I
had to get lawyers to get a tape with my
own assaults on it
so just because of you know the nature
of people and the nature of the internet
there will be people that watch this and
still don't believe the things that
you're saying what would you say to them
but then also do you understand their
hesitancy to accept the words that
you're saying right now based on
everything else I understand that like
people really believe in the media and
just believe everything that's shown and
it's like half of this stuff is just
like controlled lies to benefit the
image of others that's truly what the
media is you know like I see so many of
these stories
I see the ways that people Market
themselves I'm like that's not who you
are that's not how it goes
and I just I don't play games I don't
lie I'm a very honest truthful person I
have nothing to lie I'm very I sit here
today and I'm like leak the tapes do
what you want because the tape the
things that they've shown you is not the
truth
I can't what do you want me to do I put
out of I put out a press release saying
I didn't say these things people just
want to believe the negative in me have
you been able to speak to the women that
say they were affected by your words
have there been conversations between
there was no words but had there been
conversations between the person saying
there are words I don't know when this
all happened
a coach tried to be like you said this I
was like I didn't say that
I went and apologized to people I was
like I didn't say these things I don't
know if y'all are deaf this isn't what I
said I didn't want this Olympics to
happen I think I just like been hit and
I was on the bench drinking I was like
we should all go back to our [__]
countries like we should all just go
home I didn't say anything third world I
didn't call anyone an animal I didn't
call anyone in Edward I got attacked on
the court so many times I had this one
girl who I found out was in the wedding
party of one of these Vegas teammate
girls this is actually the girl that
kicked my stuff everywhere so I'm like
oh there's a little chain of y'all just
not liking me
um
call me ugly called me slow called me
lazy I think this girl that had all the
things to say to me is kind of just like
projecting lies to the media and I think
that's really coming from a dark place
within her so I'm like I see I see how
people act I see how people move like I
don't need to talk to you I see it you
lying you doing this and that like why
would I need a relationship with you
this is a this is I've I've struggled a
lot with the Australian team I've said
constantly like I've dealt with
teammates with black face I've dealt
with coaches lying coaches pushing other
athletes to talk badly about me in the
media
there's been a lot I've I've loiled up
with the with the Opals before like this
isn't anything new
um but for other people like this is a
big like like me having my name like
ripped through the media is just another
day for me
well I was going to say how do you feel
like that report specifically
just affected how maybe people view you
that report specifically it's
frustrating has that been hard it is
frustrating because I feel like I've
I've used so much of my life to try and
push black women to the front and on a
pedestal
um especially growing up in Australia
very whitewashed I've had to deal with a
lot of racism I've had to deal with a
lot of things as a black female
um so for someone to really like
attacked my character and say these
things when they're not true it's just I
see that as sick in the head I I see
lying on a public level is sick
yeah
what do you think playing with the
Nigerian team could represent for you
and is it a thing that you're going to
do where do you stand I hope I really
hope Australia releases me and FIBA
allows it
um because my fans miss me playing I I
would love to do another Olympics Paris
will be Fab there's nothing like the
Olympic Village it's like one of the
most inspirational places ever uh and my
last Olympics was hideous Rio Olympics
was horrible
the Rio Olympics was one of the worst
times of my life and that's a reflection
of the coaching staff it was a
reflection of the team
and I would I would love to stop fresh
with teammates that understand me look
like me and and appreciate me and
respect me I've been talking with the
Nigerian coach every like
it was every day when this all first
happened but you know coach Otis and I
are pretty tight and he has my back and
I love him for that
does basketball still make you happy it
does good I have so much fun hooping
it's brought me so much love
um I just feel like I've just really
struggled it's funny like China love I
don't know if it's because I don't speak
Mandarin I don't really understand
what's going on I can just go go I feel
like I'm just playing I'm very like la
la la like I just want to do my job I
remember saying in the medium
when I came back to the Australian team
after the blackface issue
they're like oh still asking something
about friends I was like I'm not here to
make friends I'm here to just hoop I'm
here to hoop with my team and my
teammates we don't have to be best
friends you don't have to be buddy
buddies yes respect each other on the
court lock a room that's my that's my
teammate I'll bat I'll go to battle for
you you know my teammate but you don't
need to be my best friend away from the
court and that's how I really I'm an
only child right I'm very good at being
on my own doing my own thing I don't
need someone to hold my hand I don't
need a buddy to do everything I'm a very
independent move alone female
um
but at the end of the day
I don't know what it is I don't know
what it is I really don't know I really
don't know the thing is you are very
interesting to me for a myriad of
reasons
um but what I hear also just when you're
talking about this there is something
about identity as well because you talk
about you know being black growing up in
Australia I believe you grew up with
your mom who's who is white correct your
dad's Nigerian also too you come here
and I feel like I really do this on some
levels you are a lot of different things
right your presence generally is Big you
both also physically are big you are a
bubbly person you are somebody who likes
to talk you are beautiful you are very
good at a very specific thing but you do
other things and I'm sure that people
have wanted to put you into this one box
even though you are able to do a lot of
things there is just a lot that is Liz
and like I said I understand that
but I just wonder in what ways that has
just made life difficult for you not
because of you but because of how people
see you and that's something that you're
likely having to think about every
single day because you are a lot of
different things if that makes sense
it's funny one of the one of the members
of the Australian team he said
he's like I couldn't be you you have so
much going on and I I forget because I'm
me and I don't really look at what other
people are doing that's one thing like
I've had so much going on for me I don't
look at what sponsorship she has or what
money she's making
on this like I've never I've never
wanted to take away from other things
other people because I've always had so
much going on for me
that I think people really don't like
that I have so much going on I don't am
I meant to apologize like I don't know I
I just this is a small women's sport is
a very small pool with a very small
light on it and when you get a big
great white shot like me big old killer
whale in there
and I'm just taking I'm taking up a lot
of this pool
there's not there's not a lot of food in
this pool when I'm eating it all I'm
taking everything but then I can like go
to the ocean and do other things as well
all the little fishes in that pool don't
like it
so you would almost you to you you'd
point to that is like a big reason why
and your eyes maybe have been fully
embraced I've I've been at events I
remember going to Coachella and I was
staying at the big zandara
um it was with Adidas so staying at the
big zenyara
this amazing Resort everyone gets their
own filler at this Resort right I was in
The Villa I think Trey young was in a
villa there was another athlete with me
she was in a hotel
she's an older athlete
we were all meant to go to like
Coachella festival together that night
she was drunk in the hotel room crying
complaining about me being in the Villa
crying about you know all the young
girls coming through taking the light
blah blah blah blah like I I get told I
hear things about how people complain
about me [__] about me is sick of
seeing me with the things I have and
want to take that away it's I don't
think I know I know these things
it sucks that people really mentally
elect that like see me
with things I want to take it away like
I've walked into my Sparks locker room
and girls are talking about how much
money I'm making at Adidas
I was the highest paid
other girls don't like that I'm barely
in the dummy bear and Bailey in America
I don't know I'm just I'm just trying to
do me and not ruffle any feathers and
just take what comes to me but that
still pisses people off
you know I'll be the first person to say
that nobody should read comments they're
ridiculous and you should not read them
that's why I don't go on Twitter I did
not go on Twitter because it's like
y'all just saying anything on this on
the I'm sorry it's called X now X now
but I say that because as I was watching
a lot of your stuff a lot of the
comments are just saying she could have
been the best WNBA player ever and I'm
curious was that the goal of yours is it
still how do you feel when people say
things like that no that was never a
goal of yours
do you feel like you could I didn't even
know what the WNBA was when I got
drafted and when I got to the dumb NBA I
wanted out straight away
why would I want to be the best like why
for what you don't treat me well I've
never been in a situation where I've
wanted to be the best at this most
situations I've wanted it to be over and
get out
what do you want to be the best at
um living my life
and I feel like I drew that very well
um for me like a million layups
it isn't filling my cup like
I really don't think I was put on this
Earth just a hoop I feel like there's so
much more to life than just sport I'm a
Creator I'm a creative
I love
making businesses and running businesses
and startups
um I was never even a sporty kid like I
started hooping at 10
just to make friends I didn't watch
sport as as a teenager WNBA was never on
TV in Australia
um I saw a little bit of LeBron Kobe uh
Shaq growing up you know everyone always
called me Shaq I hated that I never
wanted to be a post player yeah it's
like you want you you wanted me to be
the best you guys wanted to be the best
I just like the hoop and have fun and
shoot the [__] I like I like being the
best at ones with guys
like yeah it's like I do you view
hooping differently than what people are
putting it on it's a hobby for me it's a
hot like yeah it was my Beyond end all
in my 20s but I'm a 30 year old woman I
think people forget I'm in my 30s I know
I look good I've got something like
skins yeah I got these chubby cheeks
like and a high pitch boy everyone
thinks I'm so young like I'm always loud
and running around but I'm really just
like
I'll be good at what I want to be good
I'm good at anything I apply myself to
I'm that type of person well I mean you
you hold the record yeah I hold the
record for scoring most points in a WNBA
game I believe was 53. yeah do you think
that will ever be broken oh yeah
definitely who do you think will break
it if you had to pick somebody playing
right now
Sabrina
I think Sabrina's really coming into
herself
um and she's probably a couple of years
of like from really taking over the
league I think everyone breaks is going
to be host chewy
um or plum yeah if I was going to put
money on any girls would be those three
when you did that
did it feel like it in the moment you
know what's crazy when I did that I
didn't even know I was doing it I didn't
know it was a I didn't know the record I
didn't know I was breaking it until I
was on the bench and it was said and
done like if I knew I would have kept
going for the 60
but it's it's funny here in the WNBA
like analytics and data and record is so
big this is something I never grew up
with I think in Australia like we don't
really it's like win or lose that's all
we care about like I didn't know
that's actually this in Vegas I didn't
know those like records for like 10 plus
point games in a row oh yeah like
consecutive yeah yeah but like people
are really playing for their records
like out here
I've never seen you know those one game
a girl got subbed and the coach was like
I'm sorry like we didn't hit you your 10
point record tonight like this is the
end of the record I was like I didn't
really realize like that was a thing
that's in people's minds when they go
out and who like the last thing I do is
like put on my shoes and be like Oh I'm
gonna break a record today
I just I don't know it's interesting
yeah but you but you did it yeah I did I
did like it's just the thing I do it's
like yeah and I was the first woman to
dunk in the Olympics yeah I didn't go
into that dunk being like oh this is the
I'ma make history I didn't even know no
one had never dunked I really thought
Lisa Leslie had already done that like I
didn't know until it was done this is
what I mean I'm just a girl who hooped
yeah I'm just a big ass girlie who
played some boss ball and has so many
other dreams and aspirations in life
there is so much more than this is
basketball court I mean I think it is
true you really do love it I know that
you still do the runs in the valley with
the guys I saw that I was there
yesterday getting dunked on for what
because I love it I love hooping I love
competition but
it's just who there has been like a big
source of just you know support and
encouragement you know George Johnson my
trainer his like big brother
like Uncle Vibes I've never had he has
really taken me under my wing he's my
big protector and I literally sent him a
message yesterday
I was just like I thank you for all the
love and all the light you've brought
into my life and all the inspiration
because I get to sit there and watch
Jordan Clarkson train you know he's my
favorite ain't nobody ain't nobody
dresses I better say no he was dressed
bruh he dresses how he hoops and like
all these kids these days you care too
much about what you wear into the game
and not about what you like how you play
in
like too many people care about their
little walk-in outfits than the actual
they gotta get the pick you know that's
what you got to do on the court and for
me it's like I used to get bullied about
like wearing suits and like dressing
well to games now y'all hiring stylists
to the game like yo the things I would
do and you talk down on me about like
you're all doing it I just I don't know
you know I do have to make sure I ask
you this as we probably in the final
like 10 minutes or so I want to talk to
you about Skyler yes um because I know
that is somebody that you truly enjoyed
playing with and somebody that who you
said you said before is that anyone you
want to like clear stuff up with is
there anybody that you would like I
don't know I don't really I don't have
anything to mend with that girl I love
Skyla but I would love to hoop with her
again like if you had a question like
who I want to who thinking there's a
team oh God can we make a Miami team I
know everyone's trying to expand the
league first of all first of all let's
expand the CBA then expand the league I
feel like that needs to happen first
like expanding the league is just such a
like oh look at this instead of look at
the real issue that we need to work on
um but I would love a team in Miami I'll
be GM play a GM if that ever happens I
don't know wait tell me the starting
five in this dream world Miami team who
do you have
okay if we got star in the one
um I'm trying to think who's coming out
of college that I want like to draft as
well
um well we have what Haley there's angel
I'm thinking of people that are playing
right now yeah
trying to think who else I want I'm just
adding my two I'm like you don't know
anyone current I do the current but I'm
trying to think like who can I get in
the next draft I feel like is Haley or
angel in the next draft I got my I love
I love Haley Angel could be the next one
no oh she young bro Angel would be in
her what her second year the one coming
up oh really wait that was her first
year of college last season this would
be her third coming up I think
three
I don't know Angel would be as you're
saying no but I think Angel might but
keep going I was trying to think okay
let me just think of like WNBA girls I
probably have Skyler in the one who I
want is my two
I love baby I love raquana Williams so
much she's like one of my favorite
Shooters and I play I played in Tulsa
with her like day one I love Z
azzary Stevens like that's my ride or
die for life I don't know if I'd have
her in the three or the four
she'll probably want to be the three
full of four
hmm
I can't um
um I really want to play with Cameron
prank I love that yeah oh we also didn't
say Caitlyn I mean there's so many oh
Caitlyn yeah but she ain't gonna pass me
a ball she ain't gonna pass through the
ball she gonna go for 50 points yeah so
I gotta keep that too might break that
record honestly it's probably gonna be I
gotta think about me as well when I'm
making this team like you can't be too
hot girl copy two I gotta get the rock
as well
okay okay so you have Skyler who is
somebody that you really want to play
with and also show you but I can't I
like I love all these like young girls
coming out like Kim I I wanna we've been
talking about training together as well
Cam and I she's so lovely I just love
lovely girls and they're just like beast
mode on the court and just like you can
leave it on the court you can leave it
on the court people be taking this [__]
home with them leave it on the hardwood
baby but have you been able to talk to
Skyler about everything that's going on
if not what would you say what words
would you give her probably about to
text her after this tonight
um I've just called I literally called
up on everything on the car on the way
here because I'm not on socials like
that I'm really I'm like I'm days behind
the news always
um but I feel like she's a woman that's
really been
um disrespected by the league
the league and mothers just don't it's
rough I'm I'm I'm not a mother not yet
but I I just don't see myself like
raising a child and being a professional
athlete I saw dierka Hamby do it and
it's I just don't understand how you
juggle being a pro athlete and and a uh
and a mother at the same time like it's
a different level of power and just like
you're looking after these children and
you try I can't even get myself out of
bed after a training session let alone
like get up and feed my baby yeah no I'm
so amazed by Serena right so it's like
when this is a women's league and you've
got mothers like we need to do
everything to help them and protect them
raise their children while doing the
best they can on the court like it's
crazy to me it's so crazy to me like we
have wounds baby yeah yeah so you're
like you just want to say to Skyler like
I see you I see you I love you I think
you're one of the best in the league
you're not only a player you're a mother
you're a businesswoman you're amazing
and I've I've thought that since the day
she's been drafted and I got to play
with her back in Tulsa back in Dallas
like we've been through it together like
we've we've seen a lot together
um I don't know if she's she's seen a
lot in Phoenix as well but I don't know
I feel like we all gonna have really
bestseller books in a couple of years
all of y'all oh there's a lot of tea
there's a lot of tea to be spilled and
you know I'm messy
is there a day where you feel like a lot
of these things that have happened
whether that is in your book you will be
you know fairly explicit about the what
the who the what happened because I
still think even with this there are
gaps people are going to fill in which
is fine but that's just because you know
the lack of wanting to go all the way
there about The Who and the what but
that will happen even now maybe like
I've I've
recorded every phone call I've taken
photos of every tweet every message for
like the past 10 years of like people
who have done me dirty
um and I'm working with like lawyers to
see like what's the best way to like so
I can have the upper hand it's been 10
years of people trying to
speak down on me to fame me tear my name
through [__] lie on me so it's like
now that I have this here and I'm done
with basketball Australia how can we
really go after these people
who have who have made my life difficult
not held difficult but I'm also really
grateful I'm really grateful for the
people who showed me their true colors
and show me their true nature because I
don't want anything to do with you and
like my life is so beautiful
I saw in an interview with Amazon you
said that right now you're in your shut
the [__] up yeah what does that look
like for you I don't know now I'm out of
it
like oh I'm talking no I'm talking what
I was I was like shut the [__] up you
know I'm like maybe it's because it's
Leo season and I'm just lame let's start
being social again I'm outside with it
and then when the weather gets cold
again I'll probably go back in my little
house so then what's the era now what
era is this oh [__]
right now it's birthday month era I
don't know I'm just like I'm just in my
truth living my truth era I've always
tried to be like that I've always tried
to be
I don't know man I've dealt with a lot
it's been very my career and dealing
with other females in this world has
been very Black Swan that's the only way
I can really explain it I don't know if
you've seen that movie Natalie Portman
this is the this is the only thing I do
want to say and it's not to push this
point it's just because I understand how
people are going to receive some of the
things that you have said things have
happened to you no doubt I think women
generally just generally they're hot
there have been things that have
happened to you that have been
incredibly unfair
but there has to be some element or some
sort of
responsibility not of the unfairness
that happened to you but some level of
responsibility you take about what you
could have done to contribute to
anything I don't mean that being treated
badly but I mean situations that you
have been in what level of
responsibility do you take for the
moment that you're maybe in now or the
moments that you have had
I don't really know what you mean like
what role have you played in any of
these things that you did not like that
happened to you because you've named a
bunch and they have been bad but has
have you been solely the victim in every
single moment
um do you understand what I'm asking I
don't want to like play a victim but
it's just like I've never been in locker
rooms and treated girls how I've been
treated I've never I don't go around
speaking badly about people I don't
spread rumors I don't
I just I've just never hung out in this
world I've never really been in this
world I've always gone to work and left
and I feel like because I never like
submerged myself into like the
basketball world that people really
don't like that for me about me like
guys I'm like I'd come and work I'd go
back to Australia yeah you know I'm very
in and out I'm very everywhere and I
feel like because I don't lean in and it
takes me a lot to get comfortable with a
person like even now this is like so
surface level with me like
I feel like people really get offended
by that I don't know no I get that okay
then I'll I'll wrap with this question
tell me the thing that you love the most
about yourself
and then tell me the thing that you know
you have to work on
okay
psychologists okay
I didn't realize
[Laughter]
that
um the thing I love about myself is that
I'm one of one you can't compare me to
another person no one moves Like Me on
or off the court no one dresses like me
no one is effortless like I am I love it
thank you I spent a lot of my life being
bullied being called ugly being called
big nasty this and that monster like I'm
a goddess baby
I'm a [__] goddess like you can't
tell me [__] I love myself I love my
life I love the people around me and I
don't I don't have
any room for negativity within my walls
I love that things I can work on
um probably being a little bit softer
probably being lenient to people being
mean to me like this is my biggest issue
is I'll cut people off like that that is
my biggest issue
honestly that's the main thing I work
with with my therapist is I slam doors
like you
treat me bad lalala I'm gonna work with
you again I slammed the door I see it as
protecting myself I see it as you know
just not dealing with [__] but other
people were like that's a trauma
response
I will be very very clear I
anyone should ever be in any situation
where they're not being treated the
right way I don't think anybody should
ever deal with being disrespected I
think that you should always remove
yourself from situations so don't feel
like they are good for you mentally
absolutely
I think I more so just meant what are
things that maybe just could have been
different but I understand that I think
above all else like I just want you to
be happy because it is so many things
that have happened to you and I and you
are so full of joy and I am in no way
saying that you're not but I also
understand this for my personal
experience that things can pile on and
pile on and pile on and pile on and then
you're sitting there and you're like
okay well where's the where's the
where's the good in this thing
specifically
um and you have so much doing you are so
much I just don't want the bad things
that happen to you this this is the
thing like I feel like I don't sit
around and talk about the bad things
because like I'm not sitting around
thinking about them like bad things
happen I just move on like I've just
focused on the future and like My
Darkest Days is I've spoken about it
2016. I read your players tribute
article I wanted to kill myself that
whole year that whole that was an
Olympic year I wanted to kill myself
that whole year and I get really upset
when I talk about my duck days because I
have no right this is how I feel I have
no right in being depressed I haven't
been depressed for a long time but
having bad days being sad like bad
things happen to me I feel like I I
really don't
get to sink into it because my life is
so amazing you know what I mean like I
would have guilt for feelings that's a
great depressed about basketball it's
boss bull I'm depressed about you know
this is causing me depression these
situations are causing me depression
that doesn't make sense to me you know I
would get so it would make me angrier
I'd be depressed about this and I would
get angry about it that's that's like
when I was bad and now I'm just like
okay this is shitty I'm just gonna leave
I don't need I don't need to sit in
these situations but you also know
depression doesn't discriminate it
doesn't discriminate if she can hit you
like covid you can have a bad week
because the moon's playing games with
you you know what I mean and I'm very
much that girl I'm like oh my God it's
my period is it the moon like what's
going on in my life like I have to
really sit down and be like why am I
feeling weird but my bad days are so
[__] on like I really haven't been in a
fund since 2016 and like whenever I go
off and just live my life people like oh
she's she's on drug she's this and that
I'm just like yo
I'm under a palm tree in Mykonos reading
a book and you guys will just like say
anything anything someone wrote I was
pregnant people calling my mom saying
I've just had a baby
I ain't no babies up in here baby like
no not yet no
well I am glad that you do have joy
because that is very very true that is
clear to me I have so much joy that I
feel like I protect it and I don't even
share it like my life is just so
immaculate I'm so blessed I'm so lucky
like I grabbed my friends by the face
and I'm just like I love you every day
and I don't know if that's because I was
raised by a very loving
I'm an only child like my my family life
is very very loving but teen years 20s
was very tough
trying to be the perfect athlete and I'm
just like I'm not I'm not a perfect
athlete I'm a girly living her life and
you are completely yourself thank you
amazing I think who else am I meant to
be uh who am I meant to be no you were a
joy I appreciate your time thank you so
much truly thank you for your time thank
you very much you're amazing
thank you Liz and you gotta let us know
whatever happens with the Nigerian team
where you play we'll break it for you
I really hope it happens because I want
to go to another Olympics and it's just
like it's a good time and I really
respect those girly it's like it makes
me it really it does upset me because
like I love being black it's something
that I I tried to remove from myself
growing up from Australia I really spent
a lot of my life trying to be white
dyeing my hair blonde staying out of the
sun
um
but it's something I wear with pride now
so for people to like try and take that
away from me it kind of is sickening but
I would love to represent my African
Heritage at the Olympics I feel like
that would be a very full circle moment
I hope you get all the things that you
want thank you yes thank you so much for
your time thank you I appreciate it
thank you
foreign